accounts
but wait we don't have to pretend
there's actual real evidence of things
flying around in our airspace that's way
juicier than a fake video I have
feelings about this lately because we've
been
deep in UFO stuff and why the US
military is studying UFOs which they
call uaps because UFO sounds like aliens
and lucky for us we don't have to make
up videos because there are videos out
there of really interesting cases where
Navy Pilots are flying around and
they're seeing things that they don't
understand they don't understand how
they're moving they don't understand
what they are and it's really
interesting stuff the US military is
releasing these reports and they're kind
of dense and not very exciting to read
until you find the juicy data but like
it's there they're collecting stuff
we're understanding UFOs let's go look
at that stuff instead of having to make
like pretend videos with like pretty
shitty animation sorry